tous les matins les élèves de l'esn il
met la main à la pâte dans les ateliers
aujourd'hui le groupe d'apprentis
fromager et renforcer s'initier impasse
la journée dans l'établissement de quoi
alimenter leur réflexion sur leur
orientation
dans ce processus pour voir le bakoye ça
mais eux
c'est pas difficile
après la fabrication de comté direction
le labo les étudiants en bts sciences et
technologies des aliments apprennent à
identifier des bactéries ont fait cette
semaine l'analyse des poudres de lait et
ça va nous permettre de valider
d'hygiène du process en cours de
fabrication est également de valider
l'innocuité du produit
bastien profil de secours de
microbiologie pour poser des questions
sur le cursus
le jeune homme est bien décidé à se
réorienter
moi j'avais filière mécanique moto agréé
[Musique]
terminale dans cette filière ont montré
à des jeunes que les métiers de
l'agroalimentaire sont accessibles après
des parcours très différents
c'est un des objectifs de cette
opération 24 heures dans le supérieur
chaque année nous organisons les 24
heures dans le sub ssa a pris une
dimension plus importante ces dernières
années parce qu'il ya plus de
questionnements de la part des jeunes
puis nécessité de montrer que avec un
bac s un bac général
on peut s'inscrire dans une formation
bts la matinée touche à sa fin les
élèves de terminale confortés dans leur
choix d'orientation doivent maintenant
attendre les résultats d'admission
les plus jeunes ont encore un an pour
rendre leurs voeux